el gobierno alemán explicó que los
problemas actuales en los gasoductos
nord Stream 1 y 2 que conectan a Rusia y
Alemania no representan un riesgo para
la seguridad energética de Alemania eso
se debe por un lado a que los dos
gasoductos actualmente no están en
servicios es decir que no estaban
transportando gas desde Rusia hacia
Alemania pero también se debe a que
Alemania en particular desde que comenzó
la guerra en Ucrania ha aumentado
considerablemente sus reservas de gas
esas reservas de gas actualmente están
según cifras oficiales en alrededor del
90 por ciento a pesar de eso es Claro
que se nota cierta preocupación en la
reacción del gobierno alemán ante los
últimos acontecimientos respondiendo a
la pregunta de qué tan preocupado está
el vicecanciller alemán el ministro de
economía explicó que la infraestructura
crítica no solamente de Alemania sino de
Europa es en la situación actual un
objetivo potencia eso es algo que el
gobierno alemán sabe No desde hoy sino
desde hace muchos meses es cierto
Entonces que a pesar de que la seguridad
energética está garantizada todo el tema
de North Stream y de la distribución de
gas proveniente de Rusia continúa siendo
un dolor de cabeza muy importante desde
el punto de vista político y económico
para Alemania y para otros países de
Europa